aber ich habe richtig gutes ziel raus
versuchen waren nicht echt schwer
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja ich
weiß gerade über weihnachten bei meinen
eltern games aktuell den zweiten
weihnachtstag und für mich bzw uns geht
es jetzt noch vier tage zwischen den
feiertagen in den urlaub ich habe das
sehr spontan gefunden und gebucht weil
ich das immer schon mal machen wollte
und ich freue mich auch wirklich was
ganz wissen geschenk für meine freundin
die noch nicht weiß wo wir hinfahren
ganz wichtig und ich habe gedacht ich
noch mal einen kleinen block und nehmen
euch mit ich könnte euch natürlich das
ziel jetzt schon verraten dann ist es
allerdings umso weniger spannend
deswegen mache ich das einfach mal nicht
was ich sagen kann
es geht auf jeden fall in die kälte ich
war da vorher noch nie und ich freue
mich sehr auf die landschaften
ja es war auch wirklich schwer jetzt
noch etwas passendes zu finden weil
zwischen den feiertagen ist ja alles
eigentlich ausgebucht aber da war
irgendwie noch platz und ja dann habe
ich mich dafür entschieden ich würde
sagen wir fahren jetzt weiter ich
wünsche auf der autobahn hier und wir
sehen uns später gucken schon die leute
drin wollte man aus rein
[Musik]
leute wir sind jetzt hier in oslo
gekommen flughafen ist gar nichts los
also leute wir sind jetzt angekommen
ausflug es ist wirklich sehr schön wir
waren halt schon einen kleinen snack
kaufen jetzt geht es wieder ins hotel
hier sieht man das liegt ein bisschen
schnee und ich möchte mich gleich
nochmal so war es nicht aber es gibt
durchaus morgen auch dahinten das ist ja
keine also mit der aussicht bin ich
jetzt nicht ganz zufrieden aber es ist
trotzdem ein schöner architektur aus so
typisch norwegisch da können wir also
ich hab das ja lange studiert und ich
habe mich mit diesem fachwerk dafür
beschäftigt heute und damit herzlich
willkommen zu irgendwie habe ich es
schon angefangen
das ist ein richtiger norweger leute wir
sind jetzt einkommen ausflug ich hoffe
du hast mich darüber gefreut
leider gab es einen kleinen fail und
zwar meine mutter hat schon verraten
eigentlich sollte so praktisch ein
special sein
das ist war uns irgendwie immer so aber
wir sind wir haben eigentlich längst
auch nicht die besser das musterhaus
schon jetzt heute und morgen hier in
oslo und dann fahren wir noch woanders
hin
und wo es dahin geht dass verraten sie
nämlich noch nicht jetzt schauen wir
erstmal die stadt an
gestern war auch schon kurz draußen ich
bin noch ein bisschen im krankenlager
ich hasse es so nötig war jetzt wieder
ein halbes jahr komplett gesund und dass
dann ausgerechnet jetzt wieder passieren
was ist halt blöd na ja also ich wünsche
euch viel spaß bei dem kleinen schon
größer wird glaube ich und vor allem
morgen geht's weiter zunehme ist kein
ziel das du auch noch nicht weiß ja
jetzt
[Applaus]
heute schaut euch das an ich war ja
vorher auch noch nie hier norwegen ist
wirklich geil also das ist einfach dass
mein haus liegt direkt am meer und ist
auch nicht viel los
also ist nicht so richtig touristen
überladen wie es mir vorgestellt habe
bin ich gut
highlight möchten dieses coole schmidt
tutorial sehen kann mein linker was ich
hab es geht gut heute waren wir in china
ein
und zwar geht es zu den wölfen also ich
allerdings winkel ein baby war papa was
sagst du dazu
heute muss ein trockenshampoo reichen
weiß kennen das hat mir nahe zu waschen
heute muss jetzt mit dem zug fahren zwei
stunden in den schnee
informationen künftig
augsburg geht nach malle leute herzlich
willkommen
schöne grüße aus habgier wir sind hier
gestern nahmen angekommen ich hab leider
nicht mehr gefilmt
auf jeden fall in einem wirklich coole
norwegischen hotel
also wenn man hier aus zog die schon
echt cool aus es liegt doch überall
schnee und da oben ist auch direkt der
bergleute schon skifahren und du musst
jetzt mal erklären wo wir denn hier sind
und wie sie dann gefällt sind also
normalerweise bin ich ja ein skifahrer
ich war sehr sehr gern ski allerdings
sind wir hier ist nicht zum skifahren
sondern um uns die natur anzugucken
und das machen wir jetzt wir leben auch
älter und so also man sollte aufpassen
ja gut also davon jetzt nicht so viel
aber die gibt es auch wir sagen kommt
einfach mal mit und ja ich bin wirklich
gespannt die natur hier soll wirklich
einzigartig schön sein und da freue ich
mich drauf habe mich auch schon warm
angezogen ja minus acht grad und ich
würde sagen
let's go oder jetzt ist die kamera
leicht geschlagen
so leute es ist irgendwie ich bin kein
blogger das kann man ganz klar so sagen
weil ich vergesse immer dann die kamera
heraus zu nehmen wir sind jetzt hier
gerade so ein bisschen rumlaufen ist
echt cool das ist eigentlich ein
golfplatz ihr uns aber wir waren auch
schon da hinten auf dem berg marie zieht
sich gerade oben weil sie möchte hier
ein foto machen könnte ja dann mal
abchecken wie das aussieht ist auf jeden
fall alter ist auf jeden fall sehr kalt
also ich muss sagen ich war bis jetzt
schon auf den österreich aber die
landschaften hier
das ist doch mal krasser vor allem wir
sind jetzt sogar relativ also wir haben
auf jeden fall etwas ländlich trotzdem
ist es unfassbar heiß ich habe auch ein
paar drohnen aufnahmen zeige ich euch
mal kurz hier
[Musik]
jetzt einmal kurz hier ein foto machen
und hand davor ist ein gutes am nicht
das war kein schnee daran heute checkt
auf jeden fall den anderen kanal ab
heute ja mal region wo wir mal so
reisevideos veröffentlichen ist in der
video ausstellung verlinkt das scheidet
nämlich ein richtig geiles reise wieder
zusammen also an alle die immer nach
österreich fahren oder sofort auf jeden
fall auch mal nach mobbing findet hier
viel geiler da kommt man ja irgendwie
gar nicht so gut drauf was wir haben ihr
letztes auto sagt man fliegt auch
einfach wie lange anderthalb stunden
und trotzdem muss man im paradies hab
ich dann richtig gutes tier aussuchen
wann ich echt schon jetzt zu der zeit
noch einige jetzt habe ich auch endlich
mal wieder am meisten leute nach dem
jetzt fünf stunden wandern waren zurück
das ist hier unser zimmer habt ihr
glaube ich auch schon gesehen sieht
irgendwie überall so aus und das ist das
bad also ganz cool so jetzt wird sich
erstmal ausgeruht und morgen jetzt auch
schon wieder zurück nach deutschland
und dann ist dass kassel ist ja aber wir
haben jetzt 15 uhr und es war dunkel und
die sonne geht auch erst um halb zehn
auf also in 20 minuten ist es dunkel das
ist wirklich krass also man hat jeden
tag nur so ungefähr fünf stunden vom
park oder sechster
wo es wirklich alt ist also das steht da
oder so etwas zu sagen wann ich ziemlich
kann so leute
wir sind jetzt in hamburg angekommen auf
dem rückweg müssen jetzt nämlich über
hamburg fliegen und dann zurück nach
düsseldorf und können es ja noch eine
schule war ich weiß ich sehe ein
bisschen fertig aus ich bin auch ein
bisschen fällig wird ein bisschen
erkältet irgendwie war die klimaanlage
im flieger nicht so perfekt abgestimmt
wenn ich dich ganz richtig richtig schön
also das ist ja ich könnte ja auch so
schön nervös aus hamburg und sind froh
wenn ich wieder zu hause bin
und morgen ist auch schon silvester und
jetzt das video noch kombi aus was es
war auf jeden fall cool in norwegen und
den und irgendwann wieder
tja morgen morgen morgen ist richtig es
war
vergesst nicht in den nächsten wochen
auf unserem kanal ja noch das videobild
prüfen
das kann ich nur empfehlen